[Music]
okay we're here on the fifth episode of
the podcast with Nick Sharma Nick and I
have been friends for about a year
Nick I'm gonna tell everyone a little
bit about your background you ran
acquisition order you put an investor
and a bunch of direct-to-consumer of
businesses including Juby including
house which is an alcohol company and
some other ones that I was looking at on
your LinkedIn profile yesterday
will you tell people a little bit about
like the companies that you've invested
in yeah let's see GD house
black wolf nation bright land there
honestly mostly just D to see companies
that I'm like a fan of first and then
fan enough to want to be involved in a
deeper level and which one look are you
involved in all of them on a deeper
level or are you involved in all of them
in like um I would say like pretty much
yeah I would say I definitely work on
stuff like every week for each portfolio
company like I help them out in some way
every week for sure
okay great I mean exact look what what's
something that you did for like Judy
this week for Judy well today actually
pretty happy
I just finished a domain migration so I
ended up getting Judy dotco
as a domain and I just said it like
literally ten minutes ago I was like our
new primary domain that was exciting
yeah did you by Judy Co lucky had to buy
it off somebody or it was yeah it was a
five-figure Dublin give me five to five
figures is to wider like ten thousand
dollars or ninety nine thousand dollars
which one is it's it's closer to ten
there's a lot of Nagar I'm pretty good
at negotiating these domains so I did
the same thing at him where our first
offer for hint Co was like fifty and it
ended up at six you guys bought him taco
for 6k yeah Wow yeah so I'm just all
about like especially if it's a
four-letter brand like that hit the
first thing I did was get hint Co at
dun Instagram hint on snapchat hint on
Twitter and on Facebook and it was just
great for brand and I mean you did the
same thing with Native and then with
Judy I'm trying to do it as much as I
can you know Judy's a little harder
because it's a person's name yeah the
hard part is that you have to like
sometimes steal the like Instagram
handle from a squatter I really and
that's like yeah I didn't even know that
it's happening I just reached out to our
Facebook folks and I was like hey could
we get the native like yeah there you go
and I'm like okay great that was a lot
of media expected we actually never try
do you think domain names are important
like I think Instagram handle is really
important I think Twitter handles yeah
never did that well with Twitter but do
you think domain name is because like so
much of the traffic that is driving to
your site now is like being searched for
on Google or being found on social and
totally yeah google.com yeah I don't
think it's like as important but from a
sorry is that really noisy in the
background no go for it so I don't yeah
I think it's it's definitely important
to some extent like you want a good
domain I think where some brands get
carried away is when they try and put a
verb in front of their brand and then it
gets too long like like hint is drinking
calm it's usually like food and Bev's
or like fitness related things but um
yeah I mean I I like things that are
just nice sort and clean and so I was
really proud to get Judy calm but then
like other things like for bright land
I'm working on a landing page and for
house like you know things like
connecting them with PostScript and Alex
getting them set up there but yeah it's
like it's usually anywhere I try to be
proactive about like if I see them
trying to do something or do something
then I just try to think like what's
something easy I can do to help them out
yeah it makes a ton of sense yeah you
know uh like what comes like brand names
when we were trying to like you know
before were native launched you know I
was like okay I want to start this
deodorant business what's a good brand
name for it and so
went through a bunch of ideas and I was
like okay I want something liked it uh
now heads a nod towards natural but it
doesn't say like it isn't like called
natural and it's then called something
like deodorant club or deodorant company
yeah I want to be able to sell other
products and when we came up with the
term native I remember a bunch of people
were like this is a bad name doesn't
mean anything and a lot of Native
Americans are gonna get upset yeah
Native Americans getting upset happened
kind of people got upset about it is
that the first thing but we never tried
to buy like Native calm yeah but we did
have a huge issue with a trademark I
think I've mentioned this to you before
like we tried to we tried to use the
native trademark and somebody else owned
it yeah to like sort of we had to
acquire that trademark and we bought the
trademark like five days before we ended
up selling the business to Proctor and
Gamble like that was the desease saying
wow wow wow other people other people
would be like we're not gonna we're not
gonna give you an offer for your
business until you own your trademark
yeah I really think what have like pngs
advantages was they were like look we're
ready to move forward in the acquisition
process with the contingency that you
buy the mark before we close but we're
not energy do like an arm and a leg for
that yeah it was yeah high six bigger
price well so what's crazy is like you
know comparing that to a domain like
like you had to get that cuz that's the
only way that your deal would have gone
through whereas a domain you don't
necessarily need it but I'm just as you
were saying that this thing popped in my
head that Soylent was I think it was
like drink Soylent and they bought
Soylent comm off this dude who used it
to like he was into some weird [__] and
he would promote some stuff on that site
but they bought the domain off of them
for like a 100k Wow
and today I think they've like raised 80
million dollars so I think you've raised
a dime I don't know what a hundred
thousand thousand dollars yeah yeah that
is crazy we never look we never tried to
buy native calm and our domain name was
native cos calm and yeah it would be
like what is the COS is it cosmetics is
it companies what is it yeah it's like I
have no idea I don't know yeah for the
longest time on Twitter I never found
native because it's a native underscore
cos it's so bad yeah we tried to get
Twitter to do what we had Instagram do
or that's the native job well I told you
the guy who had the Instagram also has
the Twitter he's down okay I'm glad that
you've like got to keep one of them then
yeah all right we'd love to talk about
like what's going on in like that like
not just the businesses that you're
invested in I know you said like Judy is
sort of crushing a great time to launch
beautiful branding actually can we talk
a little bit more about Judy like yeah
Judy sells like a disaster kit for your
hounds which is like I mean it's good
timing because you know people are now
staying at home and realized that
disasters may happen look other people
that are involved in the Judy business
because you've told me about this I I
sort of understand it but I don't really
understand all the relationships yes so
Judy is interesting because of two
things one it's like a really sound
business the the product is is basically
a very functional product and it's
something that like provides immediate
value to the consumer so it's a very
functional and necessary product which
we love as immigrants ya know it makes a
ton of sense look I want a disaster kit
for my parents is everyone for myself as
well so look you don't need to sell me
on the business any longer I am yes so
the other reason that's really
interesting is because of the team
that's involved so you know the core
team was probably five people it was
myself
it was our ops person who's just a G
with ops a head of customer service and
then the two founders Josh who - ken is
a former fan of Rayden
then Simon Hawk who is the founder of
command PR for command Entertainment
Group but he also happens to be a
celebrity of his own being so closely
friends with Kim Kardashian and so and
he's also knows like the a-list world
like the back of his hand
so yeah it makes it it made a really
interesting for lunch because on launch
day I was learning all about a list
celebrities through Judy you know there
was like every every celebrity is posted
a Judy from Chrissy Teigen to Martha
Stewart Kim Kardashian to like literally
everybody and is that just because like
is that because Steve Huck I guess sort
of got all these people to post about it
how did that sort of happen yeah
honestly Simon I think just has like
he's a very loved guy in the industry
and in his in his network and I think
when people saw that he was launching
something that you know he developed
this brand because he saw that so many
of his own family members were affected
by disasters yeah and so I think when
they saw that he was basically launching
his brand and it was a real thing they
all just wanted to support like none of
them it's weird because none of the the
influencer posts I've ever felt like ads
none of them are like go buy this now
it's like it's all congratulating Simon
or just talking about how handy they're
Judy kids are yeah
well that's great like I'm trying to get
that word Anika
trying to get that organic like
influence but reach isn't it's really
really difficult to get down right yeah
yeah they did a really good job and like
Josh who's the other founder is the
president of Ramona so he he's just a
beast of an operator and so making sure
like especially on things like logistics
and supply chain
she's arcing marketing like he's he's a
genius is he related to like the founder
of LVMH I thought the president of
Rimowa was like the guy's son or
something like Bernard no I think he's
related to them I have heard that name
come up
maybe maybe Josh replaced them or he
like took a different
role in the company yeah sure okay let's
move on to like what's going on the
direct consumer industry yeah because I
feel like um you know you're you're in
touch with a ton of different brands and
they're certainly like a perfect storm
brewing right now I think there was all
of a sudden people were worried about
profitability and not just like top-line
growth and so like when Brandis sort of
shut down its operations when outdoor
voices had whatever issues that it
recently had people realized that bottom
line really mattered and then all of a
sudden like you know the stock market is
collapsing and so investors are gonna be
a lot more cautious when it comes to
writing checks and then finally no one's
going outside because you know cope it's
cause it's in the stock market to
collapse and you know all of a sudden
the pair of Nike shoes that you
ordinarily wear when you were running
outside don't really seem necessarily
any longer right what look would you
know do you think that the bottom line
mattering or a kovat is it sort of
having a larger impact or is it just
impossible to tell right it is kind of
impossible to tell because you know
we're kind of in this like sheltered or
hibernation stage right now where we
haven't like fully accepted that okay
this is the reality and figured out the
adjustments around that we're all kind
of in this like like I'm sure you said
that New York Times article around how
people are just like turning to junk
food I know just from portfolio
companies and chatting around that like
cookware is doing really well
beauty's type of stuff isn't doing as
well like anything really related to
going out but anything that promotes
happiness or calmness or wellness while
you're staying in has just been crushing
everything from like fitness fitness
gear and jump ropes and and bands all
the way to like adapt the gin drinks are
crushing you know cookware I said is
doing well it's it's kind of weird
though but it will be interesting to see
like when when all this stuff does
settle down what how will people adjust
and what will people start to realize as
their priorities you know I don't think
people are going to be rushing to spend
a hundred dollars to get you know face
wash customized to their zip code
anymore
yeah like it should things things the
perspective of money will definitely
change yeah it's crazy how fast that
happens you know took like ten years old
I feel really blessed and their wallets
to feel fat and then to feel like hey I
want to spend money making myself happy
- all of a sudden yeah like this seems
like a crazy luxury to have a customized
face wash yeah right I mean if you think
about like that's literally a way right
it's like you used to have like a $25
Target suitcase or you have like a
$5,000
you know Saks Fifth Avenue set yeah and
then away kind of came in and found that
like high earners but not rich yeah
Henry playground the Henry playground
yeah and then but I mean they just they
just had to let go of like 60% of their
staff the worst part of the people who
get affected who you know just don't
know how they're gonna pay rent in two
months
yeah I guess look um what's a good stuff
that I mean covert is obviously a
complete catastrophe for the country
yeah like that's heartbreaking and like
you know I think about it like I think a
couple days ago I saw that there were
nearly to tell 2,000 deaths in the
United States on a single day and I was
like this is two-thirds of a 911 on a
single day and it's gonna happen again
and tomorrow it's really heartbreaking
you know you were talking about some
businesses that sort of makes or that
are doing well as they're like you know
just by virtue of the fact that people
have to stay in cookware companies
Fitness fans and you're right like I've
tried to order fitness products and the
weight is like a month or now yeah I
waited to get a job broke yeah it's
crazy do you think that that
acceleration is permanent so for
instance if you if you have an order
from instacart before and now you do do
you get off of instacart are people
gonna be like yeah I want a tunnel or a
mirror
I want to keep this like you know totals
and mirrors are thousands of dollars and
they have $50 a month like subscription
fees or something to that effect they're
incredibly expensive but is this now the
new reality is Equinox sort of like in
trouble or six months from now are these
direct to consumer businesses back to
where they were and equinoxes back to
what it was um well I think there's two
parts to that one is do do people like
will people trust going out and going
into a public gym again I think that
like that to me is mind boggling but the
second part is like you know how much
how much do they value getting that like
Palatine bike or soul cycle bike for
their house and whether or not they will
I think they I mean they've definitely
seen sales just jump and for them their
whole game is you know if they get a
product in your house then they can't
get have you with the subscription for
quite some time yeah and what happens to
the other company like a way Travel had
to lay off a bunch of their staff ever
Lane has as well you know a lot of
companies have just as a result of the
fact that sales were down and you can't
yeah you know it's it's a terrible thing
to have to do but at the same time if
the entire business goes bankrupt
there's nobody that can work there right
and so it's a decision but probably the
right decision what happens to these
businesses in the future do they have
down rounds do they go out of business
ultimately to like you know what happens
to a way I guess in six months or a year
it was it was probably like the darling
of the DTC community right like a huge
valuation to female entrepreneurs who
were I thought doing a fantastic job
like really admire both of them and I
know look you know I'd love to talk a
little bit more about the press related
to stuff Cordy and stuff later on but
you know what like what happens to this
a company that was doing everything
right for so long you know investing in
a brand you go to the airport
and a ton of people are carrying their
away bags what happens that brand a year
from now yeah it's tough to say yeah
it's so scary to immediate things that
come to
and as one is private equity and then
the other is it just gets acquired by
like you know one of the big big luggage
companies and and they either like
acquire it and roll in capabilities or
they basically just keep the brand going
but support the piano much better yeah
it's really tough to say I imagine
there's gonna be like down rounds for a
bunch of these businesses and like you
know aside from the founders who I you
know have a lot of empathy for because
they built an amazing business and like
something terrible happened there was a
completely outside their control and
hurt their business also a lot of
empathy for this employees that work
there and you know had bought into that
stock or exercise their options and now
all of a sudden they're in a lot of
trouble and it's not their way right
it's an Airbnb and a ton of dodo pennies
it sort of we're headed in the right
trajectory and then all of a sudden or
no longer you gonna do that yeah we'd
love to touch base a little bit about
well actually before we get there look
do you think that like do you think
there's opportunities to buy distressed
direct-to-consumer businesses so like
away travels obviously gonna be super
expensive business but look what
happened like how do people sell buy and
sell these distressed businesses to be
honest I'm not a hundred percent sure
I've definitely been doing a little more
research just because I've gotten
curious recently about it yeah but and
I've been talking to like like Mike for
example who's our friend Nick Greylock
but yeah I mean I'm just trying to learn
about it as well
it's it's like a completely new world
for me I never thought that that I you
know that all this would happen
have you ever had to learn it before
yeah okay let's talk a little bit about
like you know not just Co vid but like
let's talk a little bit about like what
happened at outdoor voices and the press
o is related to two-way travel
you know like I've seen a lot of like
articles sort of saying are there hit
jobs going on on female against female
entrepreneurs yeah I have no idea what
the answer is to that like at native we
barely got any press when we were
independent I've never been a woman so I
have no idea as to whether people are
doing that certainly seems like
something is happening but there are a
lot of terrible or male run businesses
that don't seem to be getting as much
yeah totally
I'm not sure why that's the case but you
know I'd love to like you know III think
outdoor voices and Steph Curry are very
different businesses like the away
travel you know certainly there were
things that like Steph said that weren't
great but I think if you look at
anyone's like if you look at the slack
history I had it native you know people
would put me in prison I I was like
saying terrible thing like if people
[__] up I was like how could you
possibly [__] up like this you
[__]
you know like look that's you know it's
a very intense process and yeah like you
know all of your energy is being you
know put on something so - yeah look
geez like what did you think of the away
travel one I thought it was really
unfair I was like she's got she called
like some third-party logistics company
brain-dead and as like they probably are
bad happens all the time this term I
could think of a hundred percent
I mean I've empathy on both sides I
think as an employee you know if you're
not used to that kind of environment of
like the hyper growth startup or you
know like that like I feel like a lot of
a lot of the really successful brands or
even companies that sell products like
they have a very intense marketing or or
customer success organization and it's
because and like that's why they're so
good is because they're so critical
about their marketing their sales and
their onboarding and so I think some
people are definitely like not made for
that I also think you know you probably
don't want to be yelling at employees on
public channels or private channels but
again I mean that's a
to you as like a founder if you do that
like that's up to you I've definitely
done it before so um and you know like
you said if you're if you're a founder
and and you know like I always try and
have empathy for the other person so if
like if I was your employee and you were
like how the [__] could you [__] this up
I'm not gonna get mad thinking o Moses
mad at me I'm thinking he's right he has
to deal with like you know this company
that's trying to acquire him and he's
probably dealing with fifteen other
things me not doing my job put something
else on his plate so like that's how I
would do it and that's how I have these
things and I was at the last couple
companies I was at so all that said I
mean those messages were like nothing
that I've never gotten before there were
nothing I've never said before in fact
they're like soon yeah I was like Joe
exotic when I was running native and
like everyone else was a Carroll basket
yeah I think like you know if you're
gonna do it you own it and you know you
also obviously make sure that your
employees are not you know pissed off
that they're working for you like sure
you know there's good times and bad
times and I think that's natural but
yeah I mean I think the thing on the
press too is like you know female
founded companies are just numbers wise
you know could be considered anomalies
and so I think because of that the ones
that that you know like it started way
earlier when it was the ones that go
through the red antlers or the gin lanes
and they come out you know there's like
a press tour it's like it's it's a very
normal thing where like you know brands
is launched and there's a whole press
tour between you know everybody's goal
is to get into the New York Times with a
quote so they can throw that on their
site that said I think the press you
know good or bad will follow you
throughout because people are just
intrigued by the story and the hook is
so much different than what people are
normally used to I guess that that would
be my like really zoomed out
politically correct just like
off-the-cuff thinking yeah I guess it's
two things about that one is the other
thing I thought about from like their
way conversations that got leaked was
you know they have a real commitment to
customer service that's really
incredible
you know when they were late sending
packages that's all like okay how about
we send this person ten suitcases or a
hundred suitcases to make up for it like
that isn't that's what we want from
customer that's what we want from
customer service with direct-to-consumer
businesses companies that have a total
empathy and do the right thing when
something gets when something wrong
happens and so I really admired yeah the
other thing from a press perspective
like we you know look at native I was
trying to court the press early on and
all like you know see peach like all
product process like I want to talk
about native to yogurt and not the
success of the business and what
happened was that we couldn't get
anybody did it like write about us and
then one day we're like randomly we've
created a rose a deodorant and we
accidentally we launched it June 21st it
wasn't even our goal like we we didn't
realize that it was the first day of
summer although was the first day of
summer lounge dead and all of a sudden
all these press institution picked up
the product which we never thought would
happen yeah but like we were on Good
Morning America the Today Show you know
info in refinery29 probably like 30 or
50 populations in the course of 24 hours
and I was like great like this is it you
know and in reality like I tracked the
customer I tracked our revenue from that
day and like all of those publications
got us an extra twenty five thousand
dollars in revenue and on that day
Facebook got us like 50,000 dollars it
was like we were like we we were like in
a mini viral sensation certainly like
nobody remembers it like it was in a lot
of publications and got $25,000 it's
totally well I mean what is the why do
people cordon press like this then yeah
well I think it's like you know it
serves it serves both parties right
because like you get pickup and it's
it's good exposure and then for a lot of
these outlets they just plug into your
affiliate platform
and if they can be contextual really
relevant for what consumers are thinking
which is you know jumping in these first
day of summer articles and listicles
then they're gonna try and make revenue
off of it it's actually a good strategy
for for when you try and launch stuff if
you can be super and contextually
relevant to as many people as possible
which everybody can enjoy the first day
of summer then you just increase your
chances of getting picked up and things
like that another example of something
like that like I'm fair with Judy it
like what did it happen with Judy look
give me another example cuz I have a
tough time yeah so you know with Judy
like not speaking as a as a member of
Judy but more is like an outsider
you know when Judy launched there were
like every Kardashian was posting about
their Judy kit and and then Chrissy
Teigan had posted it as well and all of
a sudden there was an angle of like the
Kardashians are promoting this emergency
kit what is it and so that became a pro
se angle there was another People
magazine article which did really well
that was something around like what this
new emergency kit the Kardashians and
and Chrissy Teigen are promoting and so
it's almost just like like just making
sparks and one in and the fire happens
on the other that make sense yeah but
that said that one's a little bit
different than like the Rose a
but similar in the sense that you you
you can there are ways to plan things
like press a lot of people tend to think
that you just cold email reporters
asking I talk about your product and
then they'll magically like pick it up
one day but the real work comes in like
figuring out the reason for them to
write about it or creating that angle
yeah because they're also in cement as a
publication like they're incentivized by
Admiral Avenue you make ad revenue buy
more page views you get more page views
by having going yeah it's like a weird
weird loop yeah you definitely have to
be look you can't just be like here's
this product please write about it you
have to say yes why I think it's
interesting to the readers that you have
I remember when my first e-commerce
business I've constantly like look for
people who have written about something
else in the space and then sort of be
like hey here's something nice doctor so
we're it was a business itself alcohol
online and so this TechCrunch reporter
wrote about a distillery in New York
City for some reason and I was like well
that's not very tech crunchy but if
you're really right about that maybe
you're really right about us because we
know that distillery and the number one
seller of their products and so he's
like okay great let me write about you
guys so he wrote about us and then like
Bloomberg picked us up and so did like
CNBC or something like it was just
random but like a cup of the kind and
it's like flywheel effect that one
single publication that can have and so
yeah look you gotta beYOU have to be
persistent but you're right those angles
are really important yeah if you yeah if
you can nail one of those anchors as
like a you know whether it's an
exclusive or or they pick it up first
then the others will definitely make a
move to try and cover it just because
you know if it's coming from like a
TechCrunch or Bloomberg then they
probably assume people are going to be
searching for it yeah did you guys hire
a PR agent already at Judy or how are
you guys doing that you guys not need
one because you guys have all these
influencers yeah they use no they use an
agency gotcha yeah yeah when we were
like running native I tried to get an
agency and we ultimately settled on one
but like before that I called up like
the guys that are sort of doing a lot of
direct consumer electic ensue more
people work in New York and they were
like yeah we charge twenty-five thousand
dollars a month plus one
like [__] crazy that's I don't know
came from there's a one percent equity
ask and I was like you don't know
anything about my business and you want
one percent of it Allah
I like the all birds and you to be
asking for one percent of it or I could
be a brand that does you know ten
thousand dollars a year and you won't
want but those are two completely
different like one is worth more than
ten million dollars and the other is
probably worth the dollar sorry how
could you just ask for one percent
equity without knowing anything else
that's insane
have you ever have you seen people like
do that kind of stuff Oh totally well
the branding agents um branding agencies
do it and still do it I haven't seen it
from PR I know there's a couple firms in
New York that'll do like that that will
do like growth marketing and they'll
also take some equity yeah but it's it's
I don't know I think that concepts kind
of weird to like it's it's almost like
exchanging currency and I think your
currencies just have to be you know say
yeah that's why we use like confusion
yeah you shouldn't [__] with changing
equity for services and it just gets
really messy also signing with somebody
and he was saying that when you get to
like let's say you know you're early and
you're like a like a native for example
yeah and you you go off if you didn't
get acquired and you started raising
like like round C and D like those
investors start looking at your cap
table thinking why the [__] does this
branding agency have 2% of the company
like just knock them off and so they'll
just end up getting screwed later oh
that's interesting yeah I didn't realize
the people who do that I mean from like
a branding agency perspective I'm a
little bit more amenable to it because
presumably your business is just started
when you work with that branding agency
that's your about that but you know it's
worth noting and you might not have a
ton of cash I was just surprised as like
this buck you know that point needed was
probably doing you know 2 million 3
million dollars a month and this person
said if we want 1% of your company and I
was like do you want one like this
company could be doing 3 million a month
or it could be doing 30,000 a month you
don't know yeah just me right that's
insane yeah I would look you know I wish
that somebody put together like a
Yelp vendors that e-commerce come to use
yeah I know there's honestly like that's
that's one of the things I get asked the
most is like who or who's the best you
know I always get like what's a what's a
great paid media agency and really where
people go wrong is is one they they just
read stuff on the internet and they you
know like agencies are all marketing
themselves so they'll all show
themselves the best and so so one
mistake is going by that the second
mistake is thinking oh you know like
this agency looks sick I want to work
with them and I made that mistake at
hint where I thought an agency which is
a sick they didn't see they they were
just they did good work and so but the
problem was you realize that like
certain agencies are built for
businesses at different stages and so
you know we were too we were too small
for that agency to really care but now
I've kind of narrowed it down to like
you know if you're like if you're under
200k there's different person if you're
between like 300 I don't know a million
two million it's a different stage and
like you know two million plus is a
different stage yeah that's a great
point San Jose are like PR and you know
everything email PR like all your
services affiliate to they're all
different at different stages yeah you
don't want to be like the smallest fish
in a ginormous pond look you don't want
to work on your agency that is also
working with like Nike and exactly
because you're never their priority yeah
exactly
it is interesting like you know at
native what happened is the first year
first like six months of the business we
lost our contract meant like the person
who was making our product it was like
I'm making this and so we had to find
another company and like the other
company that we were working with what's
like this you know I think you doing
them at this point it's 800 ever were
gonna have an 800 square foot facility
that yeah or something tiny and like it
was perfect for us because when we call
them up we're like hey we wanted to
order a thousand units a week and
they're like that's fine that's like you
know a very good quest
for us other people we spoke to they're
like you need to order a hundred
thousand units out of gate now it's like
you can't even afford that so this and
will you share what your cogs were when
we launched when we launched the
business of first $5.50 to make a stick
a nativity ever and so were so high of
715 and we were song for 12 yeah
Facebook we were profitable with
Facebook which is crazy nice but it's
the same in 2015 our CAC was like two
dollars in 2016 is four dollars yeah by
the end of 2016 we're doing a million
dollars a month so there was a ton of
even doubt that the business was
generating but like there's the cogs
went down a ton so one for like 552 that
that original manufacturer we switched
and it became like 320 and every time
we've grew they brought the cost down we
went from like making a thousand units
of G over in a week in at the end of
2015 or the beginning of 2016 by the you
know middle of 2017 we were making
21,000 units a day and so we had just
increased sales by like you know I don't
know 20 times 500 like you know 100 max
basically and and so our cost came down
to below two dollars like substantially
below two dollars and look you know what
was amazing is we found a manufacturer
that was really able to grow with us
they moved from like this 800 square
foot facility to a 20,000 square foot
facility now 40,000 square foot facility
rarely do you find service providers
that grow with you usually you go to a
service provider and you outgrow them
and they don't make the infrastructure
changes that they need and then you
gotta go find somebody new
totally totally did you ever consider
you know like especially when you were
doing let's say 5,000 deodorants a day
did you ever consider like oh I why
don't why don't I just buy the facility
to do it and buy the raw ingredients
yeah certainly did not - seriously
though like you know we were like the
business was growing exponentially and
like if you could work 80 hours a week
just on the business without touching a
single through the back end and I became
really difficult like it didn't have the
view it was just like it was also peace
of mind that it was like being taken
care of
yeah and the simplicity like when we
were like you know I sold the business
there were eight employees at the
manufacturing facility I think they're
140 and at the shipment facility there
were like another hundred people and so
you know there were eight employees and
we had created something like 250 jobs
but I only have to manage eight
employees and I think one of the things
I realized working at native was I like
one of my weaknesses is like managing
employees it's something I'm trying to
work on and like giving me structure and
goals and communicating with them well
and yeah and like I was like I can
barely do that with eight people sitting
here if there were 250 I put bullet in
my head right like maybe more than me
actually yeah and the person who was
making it was just fantastic at it like
had very few problems she worked really
hard to make them well and so that was
really give me a lot of peace of mind
that's awesome what of like other would
or other like agents you know you talked
about postcards which I think it's
fantastic when it comes to text
messaging though it's like the claim in
text messaging I really I'm not sure if
you've ever dealt with like ship monk
they're based in like Miami they do
their faith but you introduced me to
them they're like of the only three
people I've ever met that is run by a
young person that's in the 21st century
look there ya have really good tech what
are some of the other agencies that you
recommend to people or some of the other
companies they so like most media buying
I recommend metric digital they're just
like their bread and butters is dtc
brands especially if you have like a
retail presence they're really good at
that let's see texting SMS email
probably Clay vo if you're an influencer
for texting huge community is that what
you use yeah okay yeah let's see landing
pages is building on metal if I
Commerce you Shopify although you're not
really a shut your you'd rather sad yeah
which is crazy because like WooCommerce
is you know when I used to use it as
look I'm so embarrassed telling people
that I use it and now I haven't used
Shopify and look you idiot it's you guys
are like now embarrass the Shopify
Shopify is great but it offered you know
our conversion rate went down by like a
significant material amount once we
switch from moody Shopify yeah because
my checkout page I thought that like
Shopify would be better than it is
like I thought chocolate like would have
all these network effects and yeah it
really doesn't have those it's checkout
page is terrible like it's a multi-step
checkout page the coupon code box
doesn't appear on the car page but it
does business is at this point it's only
on the checkout page you can't control
the server like you know that native I
actually bought a bunch of servers like
we didn't use AWS for a long time I
actually bought some servers and prim up
and like you know server farms and our
site blazing fast and it should outlaw
you can't do that and then we used like
you know we use our subscription portal
which was that like you know which was a
lot cheaper than recharge which is what
shot which is what native these is today
like like it was free actually
and how does recharge charge you they
charge a percentage of your subscription
sales
what a beautiful business yeah I mean
look you know what we went from
thousands of dollars a month yeah it was
crazy yeah look my next business will be
on goo Commerce again and next time I
will not have any shame whatsoever no no
it is commerce you're like you know like
someone that's told mark or someone
asked Margaret Thatcher like how do you
like how can you have the position that
you have when there's 80 people that
disagree with you like how does that
make you feel she's like I feel bad for
the 80 people because I'm right and
they're wrong that's now how you feel
about what commerce yes yeah the hardest
part was just like to develop our
community it still needed some more like
there should be about well there's it
that's my biggest tough thing is finding
really good developers on Shopify like I
have one who I just have on retainer for
myself like just for myself I have a
Shopify developer who's on my payroll
and anything I need done I can hit him
up and it's just it's so necessary
because yeah a lot of times too you know
like Shopify agencies that are on
retainers for some of these brands
they're also sometimes not the best
developers and and then you know you
can't necessarily rely on just internal
developer teams either for me I like
having my own like set of tools yeah
yeah especially ones that you understand
and yeah and I think it's like it's
really hard like you know you're working
on a bunch of different businesses at
the same time and it's really hard to
say okay these guys use Unbounce this
guy uses something else this this
company a party for a landing page and
now you're like I have to like learn all
these systems yeah it's really difficult
to do all that yeah it is actually
sorry god no no God okay what are other
industry like you know directly yeah
when we launched native dealer when I
watched native I was thinking about
doing native or another mattress company
and I'm not entirely sure that I think
the mattress company could have been
even better like it seems like everyone
who makes mattress company has hundreds
of millions of dollars in sales in
industry but you know hindsight is 20/20
and like no one was really doing
deodorant at the time and today there's
like you know they're so like they're
not annoying I'm just like look this is
a three billion dollar a year industry
the two biggest players you know
Unilever in Procter & Gamble Oh have
made acquisitions in this space you know
we're we're digitally savvy
we have a huge first mover advantage we
have a good price point a good brand
where do you look how much of the
business are you looking to acquire if
you're looking to build a 10 million
dollar a year business I get it
you're looking to build a 200 million
dollar a year business you know that's
seven percent of the market that's gonna
be really difficult to do other
industries that are untapped today but
where should people be lucky you know do
you like what's a good example like when
qyp came out I was like wow this is
great
guys are doing a great job with brand no
one's touching electric toothbrush
great industry to be in what are other
businesses that like need revolution
like somewhere hard so I think like
diapers is a great business it's really
odd because to make diapers it's really
expensive you need a lot of inventory
you need a lot of different sizes and
there's very few companies that can
private label diapers you need like a
very expensive paper machine in order to
make a diaper yeah to be honest I'm not
100% sure what like the most ripe would
be just from observations though I think
pet is one that like hasn't really been
done from a product side there's a lot
of food brands that are getting out
there but not necessarily product wise I
still think there's just like I think
there's a lot on the side of convenience
and accessibility even some of these
brands that have come out with stuff
just making things even simpler so I
think that's one area I don't know the
other day I was thinking of
direct-to-consumer sauces there's no
sauce come there's no like deep you see
buffalo sauce or like dressings but I
have yeah their stuff is good yeah
probably the closest to that what are
some do direct-to-consumer friends you
really admire right now
um dude wipes is one of my favorite dude
wipes is one of my favorite because I
think they have like some of just the
funniest content dude was like the one
way of Charlie from Dollar Shave yeah
okay and it's um they they were on Shark
Tank years ago and like they they're
really good operators and so because
they're really good operators all
they've done is just build brand and
like the coolest toys possible so like
their emails are just the best other
brands I admire how rare is appalling
for you like look forward to an email
from a direct-to-consumer company like
all the emails looks so rare so
promotions Ted I'm just like I hate like
I don't look at any of this kind of yeah
highlight all in archive yeah I usually
look through and see if there's any like
cool new templates or cool things that
people are doing with their audience but
yeah
aside from like you know like I signed
up for qui B and so like I've been
checking out some of their emails but
nothing's really that great but honestly
lately it's just been full of sales
everybody's just trying to liquidate
yeah all right so I'm sorry but I
interrupted you because I think you had
a couple other friends you said you were
gonna admire that you admired oh yeah a
couple other brands you know I think
what house is doing is pretty awesome
because they're very like they're
they're super they're other
manufacturing is done literally on their
farm and they have all the bottles as
like inventory to fill and Hellena is
just a great brand marketer and so she's
really good at just pivoting and and
making things pop which is insane so
that one's really exciting for me to
watch and also learn from and then
you know on the I usually have like a
couple faves I like on the brand side
and then a couple of Fame's on the
performance side not necessarily their
good friend but they just crush with
performance they've great landing pages
great ads like really like yours is the
native one is one of my favorites just
the home page or the landing page the
cart all the upsells the payment token
holds yeah yeah you know the up stills
were crazy we have a post purchase
upsell where we sell a trial like a
travel-size do you rent we couldn't sell
otherwise right it sold for three
dollars and it's free shipping so we
couldn't sell you that and like we would
lose so much money if we sold you that
individually and you know we sell
hundreds of thousands of those many size
to your prints every month and they like
you know they're very profitable as well
like often or even I was you know like a
cops code like they're
eBay da is basically J that's their
membership fees I was like wow RT but
does almost all like you know mini-sized
we're selling because there's so much
money yeah that's awesome but yeah I
usually have like a small tablet brands
I just keep looking at their stuff yeah
yeah likewise you know I talked to the
guy who founded hims in hers for this
podcast on that and there's like when we
yeah Andrew when we launched the
business we separated our marketing
budget and we got our Board of Directors
to sort of say okay we're gonna spend X
percentage of our marketing budget on
performance and Y percent on brand look
right out of the gate no he said the
majority was still performance yeah but
that was and he's like you know we do
brand stuff like we buy coasters at bars
yeah honestly my favorite thing about
hims is Andrew is just a genius with I
call it like finding that that new
quote-unquote inventory you know like
like above urinals the coasters bumble
used to do coffee sleeves I love seeing
brands do stuff like that it's great
like I'm at to me is just like so
creative yeah and like
or borrowers on Friday night and all of
a sudden like you can you might be able
to have a conversation about it because
it's on your coaster and it's a product
that these people were like the bars are
giving away for like you know coasters
or disposables like it was really and we
cover their class - yeah it was a great
idea and but look it so I won I was
really impressed by like the marketing
channels that he had created that didn't
exist before head and then - like I've
never heard of a direct-to-consumer
business at such a young stage sort of
having the ability to spend so much
money on brand marketing usually like
you have one more inning budget and you
know you send someone brand in someone
performance but in reality you have like
these numbers that you have to hit and
he's like well this is how we do it and
what we have to invest in brand if we
want to be around 20 years later yeah to
get that's a good point yeah it's a
great point I feel like a way did that I
feel like all birds today as well yeah I
just don't know like I'd have never did
that never spent one penny on the end
one hint and I know no marketing budget
was performance - and hint yeah most of
it was performance you know actually
pretty much I would say most of the
brands that I've touched and it could
just because I work with like the
hyper-growth ones or you know more
performance based but a lot of them
their marketing budget is focused on
performance and then I they're like
what's left over or very tiny percentage
is dedicated to grammar but I do think
that like brand I mean Andrew did a
great job building hims like everybody
knew yeah everybody knew like the day of
launch basically yeah I wonder like you
know then I look back on things and I'm
like okay what is right and what is
wrong like I would really spend a ton on
brand and is like struggle to find it
and exit and struggle to sort of
maintain its valuation a way seems like
it's gonna struggle as well as a result
of CO bad maybe not necessarily like you
know spending a lot on brand and not
necessarily enough like as much on
performance then I'm like you know what
like all these brands that I really
liked aspera spent a ton on brand right
like all these beautiful out-of-home at
it's like beautiful imagery I see their
team
commercials and I'm like did you like
Vincent and go to like create this this
is [__] fantastic look I want to free
freeze this ad print it out and hang it
on my wall oh yeah yeah and then I'm
like but then you have a hundred million
dollar valuation having raised four
hundred million dollars so like uh you
know are they right to be doing this
what look what is the outcome here yeah
I mean it will be really it'll be an
interesting case study and you know in
15 years to look back on it and like
really look at what mattered cuz cuz um
I mean just from how I've seen native
like native has always been well named
native and I think hinted it really well
to when I was there was like performance
branding which is you you build your
brand equity on the back of your working
media dollars and like I think native
you guys simplified the messaging a lot
which helped that's why I like black
wolf nation as well as the company the
messaging is just simplified at hint we
did the same thing but also to some
extent a lot of these products provide
convenience and an actual function
they're also consumable which I think
matters lasts then function but they're
very functionable products and they have
functional benefits to the consumer yeah
and so as a result like the work thing I
think you have to work a little less
Gandhi brand side because if you can
show them the outcomes or the benefits
of the outcomes yeah then you just have
a stickier brand yeah that said it will
be interesting to see like I also don't
think like there's one path to doing it
that's applicable to everybody or or
right path yeah because also quite
frankly I would also bet money that some
of these companies that spend a lot on
brand probably tried to do what you were
doing at Maidan but just didn't have the
skillset to actually execute it and so
their pit was to whatever they end up
doing yeah yeah look you know it's
really hard
build a performance-based company they
said that has 500 million dollars in
revenue but I think the only way to do
that is one get investing in brand yeah
I'm not sure like like brand marketing
can get into 500 million dollar company
I'm just not sure it can get you to a 50
million company that's the crazy part
like I need like some of that
performance in order like like almost
like an airplane right like you need
some energy to take when you create that
Ripple yeah it is really great like it's
crazy to think about what like what will
happen in this community you know I
think about Harry's and the edge well
not the edge well thing and the FTC sort
of saying yeah this isn't gonna happen
you know I don't know what Harry's does
now like P&G certainly can't acquire
them they're gonna have another
antitrust problem and P&G knows that in
Harry's knows that I don't know how
Billy feels because Billy's supposed to
be acquired by P&G you know I don't know
the next few months that was supposed to
start when we were boxing in New York
that was a long time ago that deal was
supposed to like yeah that deal yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's right and so like
I wonder what Harry's like you know if I
were sitting it if I were like Geoffrey
I need Harry's I'd be like you know I
built this amazing brand somebody else
agreed to pay one point four billion
dollars for it and now I can't get this
done look what happened what is going on
in this world I now must be crazy
look if Sprint and t-mobile can merge
and so that there's only three phone
carriers if there's like if you know
United can be merged with Continental
and Delta with Northwest why can't my
dtc company sell to a strategic I'm a
direct consumer new company that has
launched in the last five years there's
an entry I think it's it's tucks and
it's also a complement
yeah it certainly complement and I
respect their business immensely I think
like you know ya are looking are our
lives both yours in mind were made so
much easier by virtue of the fact that
like Andy Don and Jeff and Eddie from
Harry's sort of pave this path for us
like you know Andy like we're gonna
build the direct consumer business
online everyone's like what the [__] is
that
and yeah yeah we're gonna spend a bunch
of money marketing and didn't know how
to spend it well and built you know
pop-up shops now there people are
copying and the Harries guys yeah we're
gonna take this door right to consumer
business and we want you to target and
it's gonna be successful there and yeah
you know when it came to when it came to
native I was like great I know exactly
what to do business like that and he did
and then I'm gonna launch him to target
like that and he did yeah and like you
know target was like yeah we know why
this is look we didn't have to convince
target you know target ya know why this
is a good deal Ares has been taking a
ton of market share and you know native
is now 12 percent of the drn's sales at
our year 13 percent it's awesome that
was over a million dollars a week there
and I'm just like I'm like we're walking
in the footsteps of like giants
and yeah unfortunately Andy done didn't
have the best outcome at bonobos I think
the outcome for Harry's is too early to
tell now you know it certainly made our
lives a lot easier
oh it totally I think like one thing
that always gets lost even back to the
those pressed pieces slamming the
founders one thing that always gets lost
is like a lot of these people paved the
way or created these movements which is
something to be appreciative of and you
know like it like you said it allows us
to have a job yeah yeah I really think
that like 60% of this industry is like
building your business and 40% is
getting the timing right like outdoor
voice is a hot brand brought in Mickey
from like j.crew as their chairman
broken somebody from like Nike that was
like president or something they just
didn't get the timing right of like when
to when to find a home for that business
and same thing with Casper right like a
fantastic brand absolute brand geniuses
that created that you know and let great
operators as well first month that they
launched that a million dollars in
revenue they were sending out air
mattresses because they couldn't receive
orders so like we're gonna send you this
air mattress until we can get you a
Casper mattress you know it's sort of
pioneered out-of-home ads particularly
in New York like I don't remember seeing
simple yet until I saw Casper no never
yeah that's like [__] all direct
consumer businesses are now doing this
and like just didn't find a home at the
right time for that business yeah yeah
no I know I know you committed to some
ads this summer what happens to those
boys do you know yeah we're trying to
like so native it's sort of agreed to do
some subway ads in New York and you know
do current sales pick up in like you
know during the summer because it's
warmer yeah and all of a sudden you
thought about sweating and you know
you're outside as opposed to when in New
York it's you know 12 degrees you're
sweating while you're walking and so we
we want to buy some out-of-home ads and
like they were pushing for I don't know
exactly what time they were pushing for
it and you know at the time I was
feeling native I pushed for you know the
summer which is now the worst time ever
to run subway out because they're so
what ridership is down probably 90% and
so we're trying to look push them out a
little bit so that we can still get some
traffic like you know you know you agree
to like a price and you're like okay
this is what the CPM backs out to based
on the number of riders right someone
has and then but you don't agree to a
CPM price you know you don't say okay
you're gonna have this many rights right
right number of dollars you say this
year the price based on your historic
traffic and that like that I was like I
had terrible timing there it's really
couldn't foresee yeah but like just
absolutely terrible oh yeah I mean it's
nothing you could have yeah it's nothing
you couldn't predict yeah I was pretty
excited though yeah it was I was super
excited too because I want to run all
these like fun ads I would say like what
stinks down here not you if you use
native deodorant and the subway guys
were like you have to be careful because
you can't make fun of the subway while
you're running
look it's you have to buy the inventory
from us you can't like be an [__] to
us and like we're not gonna let happen
this place is a [__] use- to10 avoid
the rats use native deer yeah what
stinks not you use native deirdre like I
think that would have been okay with
them but yeah I mean look it is crazy
out like
venturi has sort of changed and you know
when I talk to people who are who are
advertising on Facebook these days
they're just like prices are down on
substantial like CPMs are down because
your yachts and United's and you know
Toyota's of the world just aren't
advertising on there now yeah yeah
actually yeah totally and then the ones
that you know when all that big a
agencies pulled out then all the really
savvy people like Gus went in and
started you know creating these
campaigns yeah and be overall inventory
got super cheap yeah I remember looking
2017 Mark Pritchard who's the chief
brand officer at P&G like when on The
Wall Street Journal and he's like we're
cutting our facebook ad spend by a
hundred million dollar artists because
Facebook just doesn't provide the return
on investment that it should and I was I
was sitting there like this is pre
acquisition I was like fantastic yeah
you're missing it's fantastic out here
if you're lucky to me about running
Facebook Ads
so like yeah you're right it is that it
is that don't worry about it stop
spending meanwhile I'll go ahead and
increase my set yeah like that's what
happens in auction based platforms
totally if somebody was gonna start you
know I know we're running over time
already if someone's gonna start a new
business today what is the best way to
learn learn about digital advertising I
feel like you know you're an expert at
it you were doing it hit hit water by
the way I try to spoke to Kara earlier
this week and she was like we ran a
Superbowl commercial and causes under a
million dollars to run that Superbowl
commercial and I was like when you said
you focus mostly on performance ads I
was like okay it sounds like that's
change now Superbowl commercial
performance it's also interesting to
hear that just yeah you know you've run
acquisition a bunch of companies you're
advising a bunch of companies when it
comes to acquisition you've run your
fair share of Facebook Ads
certainly admire your expertise there
what's the first step that somebody
should do if they're cold and they're
working at you know I don't know Johnson
and Johnson or they're working there are
like a paralegal somewhere and they want
to run this direct-to-consumer business
where should they go to learn about
direct consumer advertising
um they know to be cooking yeah yeah you
can definitely text me the the main
thing like I I had always tried to find
like whether it was that one site that
was really good at educating you or like
the you know that one course or whatever
but there did it just doesn't exist and
also this world changes so fast that
there's really nothing that can
constantly keep up I found that for me
the best tool is like I just started
building a group of people that I
constantly talked to so you know whether
it's like these are people most of them
initially were just actual like
acquisition people so people like you
know the head of marketing at like third
love or Madison Reid or some of these
like big d2c brands yeah and then and
then I just started figuring out that I
could use Twitter to network and now now
like I'll talk to people who are running
you know tens of millions of dollars of
ads all the way to people who are you
know doing a thousand dollars a month in
sales and they're really proud of it
but I it's easy for me to just kind of
learn through seeing what other people
are doing and then the other thing I'll
do is just you know like stock the
really really good brands and see
exactly how they do it whether it's
they're looking at their creative you
know there's things you pick up like if
you go to you know probably even native
see if you go to natives like Facebook
Ads library 80% of the creative looks
the same that's the creative that's
doing really good and so you just like
you do that I constantly have a list
where I'll go through you know the top
like 50 or 60 brands and just see one or
all their landing pages looking like now
if I identify similarities it's because
it works you know I just I learned by
observation so I I'm like looking at
what other people doing and then
figuring out the why and then basically
taking the why and trying to make that
with my own version yeah that's a great
point I think like you know someone made
fun of us for like having a landing page
of the look like Harry's and I was like
you're you're using this as like an
insult and I pick it I picked up what
you said and put it on myself as a badge
as a compliment yeah
yeah we didn't spend the money to do it
but we looked at other people and
emulated yeah and you know if you look
at like a lot of these brands that spend
you know millions of millions of dollars
a month like we can we don't have to do
that that tests thing they've done the
testing gave us we just have to see what
you know they've come out with yeah I'm
a big fan of like work smarter not
harder
so agree with uh like sort of looking at
of looking at competitors or actually
best in best-in-class
sites to see what they're doing really
well when you said you developed like a
network of people on Twitter and
presumably slack and communicate with
them and some of them are spending you
know a thousand dollars in some of them
are spending ten million dollars a year
on Facebook Ads how does that help you
um it helps me in a few different ways
so like you know if I know that you know
if I if I know that for example I'm
helping out a telemedicine brand you
know on board new new customers and
they're a part of their customer journey
requires like going through insurance
then I have a friend who runs marketing
at another telemedicine brand for women
where they have that whole kind of
funnel and they've gone through that
whole process so for me can be as easy
as you know texting him and asking a
question in other cases it could be like
you know I I needed a Shopify developer
two months ago and so I had asked a
couple friends and right away they were
just like oh yeah here use this guy he's
the best yeah and yeah I usually just
learned that way I'm a big like
questions person my theory initially I
think the reason that it kicked off was
because I don't really have a formal
education in anything and so my thought
process was that and I also wasn't a big
reader so my thought process was
basically like instead of instead of
going to like books and instead of going
to college if I just surround myself
with the people who write these books
and I get the information first
um then I should be in a good enough
position yeah III think that's
absolutely right you know there's two
things that say look I have a formal
education and I can tell you I like
never use it on a single day unless like
you know unless someone's saying
something like requiring me to do
something that I don't want to do and
yeah you're a Harvard lawyer and you
know I don't have to do this I'm not
your slave yeah and so I think that's
the only time I use it and I think you
know you're talking about networks in
San Francisco and I started doing when
you were growing native and we're really
small as I started hosting like this
ecommerce brunch so like every Sun one
Sunday a month I would get like ten
people who are all in ecommerce into a
room and we would talk about like you
know the problems that we were having
from like in operations perspective a
personnel perspective and really a
marketing perspective I said what is VN
from you but for you guys on a marketing
perspective where are you spending money
you know it like that Network really
helped me understand the shift from like
desktop to mobile from you know mobile
static images to mobile video landing
pages colors that would work how
important creative was versus headline
you know important the you know the
display image was before it started a
video like all that kind of stuff and
like that community like aside from the
fact that it was really like easy to
voice my concerns to other founders who
came to the brunch
it was super inspirational I remember
like coming out of those brunches being
like it's Sunday at 2:00 p.m. I have
nine hours of work to do today because
yeah all these guys had such good ideas
I need to get started executing yeah in
myself Scott Swanson who I don't think
you've met but he actually used to work
at the hustle me Scott the head of
marketing at third love Hadamard a
Madison Reed and Mike do blow when he
was at the stitch fix we would all get
lunch once a month and and sometimes we
would come up with these meetings and we
all had pretty much the same customer
but we were not competing so it was
great and we would come out of these
meetings and Scott and I would take like
an idea that we discussed over lunch and
it would make us an extra hundred grand
the next weekend yeah it's
Chris but it totally did help with like
like you know third love and Madison
Reid um did a ton in podcasts and TV so
like we learned a lot about that before
we stepped into that it helped us with
figuring out things like the right
agencies you know who are the right
buyers yeah all the way down to like you
know oh I don't you know we're hiring
we're trying to hire a head of retention
how do we go about hiring that or you
know we have this issue on the team
where this person thinks they're
supposed to be doing email and affiliate
but like random issues but it helps to
have that group where you know the
chances of one of them having already
dealt with that issue is pretty high
yeah that's it that's a great point it's
like your personal like Yelp where you
have a bunch of people who have had some
experiences and it's just like
brainstorming in a way where sometimes
you need to get other people's
perspective who are doing the same thing
you're doing although it's different to
really open up your eyes for me we had
like a guy from with Eric who runs
nectar mattresses or it's called like
nectar yes and you know I saw his
business go from like zero dollars to
north of 200 million dollars and I was
just like what the [__] is going on over
there like every month we come in and
I'd be like what the [__] how is your
growth that huge and yeah really helpful
and so when I was looking at working
perspective might go to him and alright
you know need to discuss a small team
issue you know I talked to the guys that
the vine Boxer Japan crater somebody
else who is small but like sort of
growing like struggling well and like
had a lot of insight and yeah yeah I
think those networks are like
underappreciated they're like sort of
totally below the radar it's a total
advantage to yeah it really is you know
you're talking about how you guys had
different businesses to how like certain
things would work I don't know there's
like there needs to be a private equity
firm that sort of buys up a bunch of
these businesses and spreads like
everyone's biggest costs or one of their
biggest cost is certainly customer
acquisition it's got to be in the top
five or probably the top - oh definitely
you know someone needs to spread this
around cuz you're right like the
customer who's a native customer is
probably a hint customer and the
customer is a hint customer is probably
an outdoor voices customer and we're all
paying
Facebook to sort of like acquire these
customers as opposed to saying you know
we have this one email address it would
probably apply to all three of us trying
to share this resource yeah there I've
thought so much about this there was
actually a company that I think the
farthest it got as like like as
operators we're trying to do that the
furthest that ever got was like sharing
Facebook audiences like look likes I'm
gonna swapping look like some young
brands but everybody got super well one
people got really protective about their
email list especially if it was a big
list everybody was really cautious and
then secondly anything from like a
bigger company that had you know I would
say like more than 50 people they
naturally had like a chief technology or
chief privacy or chief legal and that's
where it gets really tough so it is
tough but if somebody could figure that
out or or you know it's another one I
think I'd say the screenshot one time
but it's it's if you could develop a
Shopify app the hustles like the perfect
audience for the a Shopify app that
imagine if like I was at hand you were
at native and it was one landing page
you check out on the landing page and it
pushes the order out to both hint and
native so on the back end it gets
fulfilled like a normal order and on the
front end the customer pays once puts
their information and once and it
basically goes out to two stores rather
than checking out on my site and I send
you an excel sheet or vice versa
you're saying so there'd be one check
out like one website that sells both of
our products know so well yeah it could
be that but it's more so like you know
the reason a lot of people don't do like
things like like acquisition collabs is
because it's like well who owns that
customer technically is it on my store
that they check out or your store and
then if it's if it's just another site
like Amazon then Amazon owns it so in
this case everybody wins yeah I think
you're absolutely right I think the
first step to getting there is actually
like the word step which is like the
private equity company coming in and
buying
of these businesses and start sharing
like because once they prove that hey
this kind of stuff works and we can
bring your marketing costs down thirty
five percent and that's your biggest you
know like that's the biggest line and
you have in terms of expenses now all
the sudden everyone's gonna be like well
this cancer like this company's got a
competitive advantage and we have to I
think there are certain companies that
are trying I would be surprised if
atomic and like Kim's in hers don't
share that kind of stuff and I'd be
surprised as like you know that the new
chin Lane isn't trying to do that as
well yeah it is like I like no has done
it well and like yeah you know people
are attempting it yeah yeah there are a
lot of people attempting it like a back
when Facebook would share interests with
you like I look at natives it audience
and I'd be like what are the other
things you like and I'm like great oh
he's other like like 60% of our
customers also like to honest that's how
I would find a lot of like media
partnerships we saw yeah the first time
I ever did it out it was like the skin
was in the top five and I was like yeah
this kid yeah yeah it was great and like
I was just like we have the exact same
audience and we felt like the honest
honest Cohen native had the same
audience and we have to each of us have
to acquire on customers independently
doesn't make any sense it's just the
only like you know yeah awesome Nick
really appreciate your time we're way
over already so thanks so much for being
on this on this episode if people want
to follow you if we're should they text
you which they follow you on you know on
Twitter you can text me at nine one
seven nine zero five two three four zero
or you can follow me and tweet me on
Twitter at mr.sharma fantastic Nick's
thanks so much for your time really
appreciate this I always love chatting
with you I feel like you and I have this
status of like performance marketing if
direct-to-consumer businesses yeah and
there isn't all this like hoopla
[__] you know there there's no like
you don't put yourself out there like
you're royalty you're like look I'm uh
I'm the commoner of fighting the good
fight exactly and it makes it a lot
easier to
to challenge yeah awesome awesome thanks
so much for your time
[Music]